wikipedia l'un des mastodontes du net va
avoir un nouveau concurrent avec la mise
en ligne par larousse et gratuitement du
contenu de son dictionnaire
encyclopédique agrémenté de
contributions d'internautes marie
bérurier laurent beaufils
dès qu'on fait une recherche sur google
en fait donc quand on nous avait
directement sa huitième et dia est
sévèrement facile de trouver tout ce
qu'on voit là dessus dès que j'ai une
recherche à faire sur internet c'est le
nom qui vient quasiment le premier à
chaque fois donc c'est assez pratique
effectivement archi plébiscité par le
public
et pourtant depuis hier au soir mais lui
wikipédia à de sérieux soucis à se faire
à peine mis en ligne la rousse point fr
promet de les faire concurrence quant à
son encyclopédie gratuite tout chacun
peut également participer
internet nous offre cette faculté
formidable qui est de repérer ce que les
internautes recherchent les thèmes sur
lesquels ils veulent nous voir
développer du contenu et ça va nous
permettre d'orienter très fortement
notre développement éditorial elle
il a fallu deux ans de travail à la
rousse pour peaufiner son encyclopédie
contribue-t-il sur internet
objectif principal éviter le gros
défauts reprochés wikipédia sont peu de
fiabilité car sur l'encyclopédie en
ligne américaine n'importe qui peut
modifier n'importe quel article sur la
route point fr ce travers ne devrait
plus exister
l'article est créé par l'auteur ne sera
jamais modifié par un autre contributeur
il est vraiment maître de a à z
construire une réflexion un fils de
raisonnement et de pouvoir va vraiment
avoir quelque chose d'homogène avec son
plan saisie d un concept lie ces bien
pensants qui ne trouvent pas et frau
évidemment du côté de wikipédia je crois
que la pluralité d'auteurs avec des
auteurs principaux compétents dans le
domaine
et puis désordre qui apportent leurs
points de vue quand il un internaute qui
comprend pas il pose des questions dans
la page de discussion
cette pluralité d'auteurs elle permet à
celui qui lie la page un peu d'exercer
son raisonnement scientifique ce sont
sont la façon dont il exerçait son
jugement finalement alors wikipedia
contre la rousse point fr c'est sans
doute le début d'un vrai bras de fer sur
internet
en tout cas c'est sur la bonne vieille
encyclopédies traditionnelles à ses
beaux jours derrière elle